the jurgen experience jimmy you kind of
look like john travolta did anyone ever
tell you that
do people tell him that all the time
not recently but uh yeah you do have
because i've never seen you i've heard
of you but there's really no pictures of
you online i was while i was watching on
gray last night i tried to incorporate
you and i never but you do have a giant
but not that but i mean like a in shape
good looking thank you yeah what did gad
said said you look like uh alec baldwin
no it's bill maher bill maher yeah yeah
because john travolta now looks like if
you and joe had a baby that's what
johnny looks like right now
if we just put john's face on joe's head
there you go i met john travolta once
you guys ever meet him yeah i met him
yeah yeah i met him at fear factor his
wife uh kelly preston
you've since passed uh she was on the
show oh wow yeah yeah i did um david
letterman in 2013 and it was first time
on
television doing anything and it was a
big deal for me not only get stand up on
on letterman but john travolta was the
other guest so i remember like that week
like my mother was just telling all her
friends she was like i'm i'm gonna go
see john travolta on letterman and i was
like also like your son is doing
stand-up but she never she just cared
about travolta she was like i can't
believe she was kept picking out
different dresses she's like what do i
wear and
so
i did and my mom and dad who were
divorced it was one of the first times
just before i had my kid my first child
so before i had my first child my mom
and dad never talked they had like a
divorce and they just you know
especially as i got over 18 they were
just like we don't talk anymore so it
was one of these things where like it
was the first time like my mom and dad
were going to be in the same room
and
and i'm so it's like all nerve-wracking
and i'm
about to go do the show i bought a suit
the night before from this place joseph
a bank there was only like a strip mall
in scioscia long island and it was like
three sizes too big so i just had this
oversized suit on
i was like really nervous and
i go down and john travolta is on the
couch
you know um crushing it he's john
travolta and then i'm about to go up
next to do stand up and he um
you know the commercial break happens
and he's walking out and i'm standing
there like nervous with my 3x suit and
he stops and he looks at me and he goes
you're on a beautiful suit i was like
thank you i was like i feel like it's
too big and he was like no it's
beautiful i was like oh yeah and my
mom's sitting right there [ __ ] dying
that travolta is like looking at me
she's like trying to smell his breath
and so
travolta says to me he goes what do you
what do you do what's your talent i'll
never forget he goes what's your talent
i was like oh uh i'm a stand-up comic
and he was like oh very nice and then he
was like you seem a little nervous and i
was like yeah yeah and then
and then he puts his hand on my chest
like it just puts his hand right on my
chest like right right jesus right in
the right right in the middle right in
the heart right on the no seriously like
right in the middle and and and i was in
my head because i was like you know i
got a fat nipple so i was like i hope he
doesn't think like you know i'm not
jacked and then and then he and then he
goes um why is your heart beating so
fast and i was like because you're
you're judging you're massaging my
nipple
and he goes don't it was he goes don't
be nervous about what you're about to do
and he goes you've done it already and i
said no i'm actually going on after you
i haven't done it yet he goes no you've
done it already it's over
and i was like are you stupid i no
are you dumb [ __ ] i was like
[Laughter]
i was like
i'm going on next
and he was like the work is done
and then
i i was just like what do you mean and
then the whole time his hand is on my
chest he goes i'm sure
that mr letterman had to vet you
personally i'm sure that you've had to
practice this set a thousand times
before you got to this moment so the
work is over so now you just have to go
be in the present that's your only job
is to be in the present because the the
set that you're about to do is done
you've completed the work already now
it's just living the moment which is the
fun part of the hard part of the journey
but the hard part is over all these
words and
my heart is like slowly
going down like i swear i was getting
like very very calm
and he goes i'm going to stand right
here and i want to watch you live this
moment he goes this is rare that i get
to see this at the level i'm at in my
career to see someone get to begin their
journey in entertainment he goes i'm
going to see her i want to watch every
second of this i'm going to be here for
you and i and with that
the letterman people are like chris
you're on next and give me that little
push david letterman this whole time i
hadn't even listened david letterman was
already being like and our next guest
you know stand-up comic you know making
his uh uh appearance making his national
television debut on the david letterman
show i didn't even hear any part i just
hear please welcome chris to stefano and
with that i'm going out yeah look at how
big my [ __ ] suit is
play it out play it out
go go from the beginning
so you you had just been touched by john
travolta he is in that back corner
literally if you look closely i almost
have a boner
and look at how big that suit is thank
you oh looks good
you guys doing i'm from new york you can
tell i put on the new york accent that
done it's new york just skip the r
it's not was
always we don't need to i don't want to
do this to you yeah
it's it's all good and um
it's the worst thing ever do you want me
to finish the travolta story oh i'll
tell you sure
knows
the reason why there's more to it is
because travolta i told you he goes he
kept telling me you know i'm gonna watch
this moment and all that and it was the
most
um
calm i ever was still to this day doing
tv like i was more calm the first time
doing that five-minute letterman set
then i was doing a whole netflix special
or whatever i was so calm because of his
words and then when you came backstage
was he naked when i came backstage i was
looking to see him and he was gone and i
said to my mom i was like mom where's
john travolta she goes he left
immediately as soon as you said hi my
name's chris he walked away left went on
he so he just did that for you for me
which at first i was angry i was like
where's john and then as time went on i
was like oh that's the nicest thing
anyone could have ever done for me